أنت تعلم أنني لست رجل أعمال أو
رائد أعمال ، فأنا لست مراسلًا تجاريًا بالفعل ،
لكنني
أفهم المحصلة النهائية وكيف يجب أن تحصل
على ربح ، يبدو أنه يتعين عليك
دعم الكثير من أنشطة أوبر من
أجل  للسماح بحدوث ذلك ، فأنت لا
تحقق ربحًا ، وانخفض الاكتتاب العام الأولي
الذي بدأ مرتفعًا للغاية في مكان ما حول
120 إلى نصف هذه القيمة مدى
استدامة النموذج الذي نعتقد أن
هذا النموذج مستدام تمامًا الآن
نحن في المراحل الأولى من  بناء
هذا النموذج ، لا يزال العمل التجاري على سبيل
المثال ينمو بنسبة 30 زائدًا في المائة على
أساس عالمي وفي أي وقت يكون لديك
نشاط تجاري به
حجم سوق يبلغ تريليونات الدولارات من حيث
النقل والطعام والتجارة المحلية ،
فمن المنطقي بالنسبة للشركة أن
الاستثمار بالرغم من أن هدفنا للاكتتاب العام
هو زيادة رأس المال الكبير
والآن لدينا كل رأس المال الذي نحتاجه
للانتقال من فترة الاستثمار إلى
فترة الربحية ولكن هذا
سيستغرق وقتًا طويلاً.